NICO WEBER: Welcome to the last
time slot at Google I/O.
I'm Nico.
I'm glad you guys
could make it.
So did you have a good
time so far?
Any favorite sessions so far?
[AUDIENCE SHOUTING ANSWERS]
NICO WEBER: Yeah
I saw that one.
I really liked that.
So you might have noticed
it's kind of hard to
get tickets for I/O.
One of the easiest ways for me
to get in was to give a talk.
So that's why I'm here.
And it's very different to watch
all the talks when you
know you'll be talking later.
So one thing I've been paying
attention to a lot is what the
presenters do with their hands,
knowing that I have to
do something with my hands.
So all the professional
presenters did like this.
I guess they read some book on
body language and read that
this means open and relaxed.
And all the more engineering
types of guys were like this.
And then they did a
stand in between.
And I guess my conclusion is,
talks are more fun if you
don't pay attention to
the hands of the
presenter so much.
So don't look at my hands.
I'm going to be talking a little
bit about 3D graphics
on Android.
It Earlier this year I ported
Google Body to Android 3.0.
And I'll just share my
experience there, I guess.
So who here has Google Body?
Quite a few.
So for those who haven't, if you
just do a web search for
Google Body and pick the first
hit on most search engines,
you'll go to this thing here.
And it's basically a
human anatomy app.
Users call it Google
Earth for the body.
So there's a 3D app
of the human body.
You can zoom in, pan around.
There's a transparency slide
on the left here, where you
can look at skeleton
and whatnot.
There's a search box
up here where you
can search for stuff.
And you might not have known
that the liver has kind of an
interesting 3D structure
from the back.
You can click on things to
learn how they're called.
So this is the colon.
And that's basically
Google Body.
For April 1 we had Google Cow,
which was kind of popular.
So it will be a little
while until it loads.
So that's the same
thing for a cow.
It was pretty popular so
we left it in the app.
So that's Google Body.
So Google Body is obviously
a web app.
It lives in the browser.
And for 3D display, it uses
a technology that's pretty
that's called WebGL, which was
also demoed in the keynote
this morning and there were
a few talks on that.
So there's no plugins or
anything needed for that.
You just need a new browser.
So for example, Chrome
supports WebGL.
Firefox 4 does.
WebKit, which is the Safari
prerelease version, I guess,
kind of, supports WebGL.
There's an Opera
11 preview that
supports WebGL on Windows.
But sadly the Android browser
does not support WebGL yet.
Google Body is a 20%
project by about
five people at Google.
So Google has this concept
of 20% time.
One day of the week you can
work on whatever you
want, if you want.
And they were looking for
someone to make Google Body
happen on Android.
So I figured, yeah that
sounds like fun.
I'll do that.
And let me show you
how is looks.
So Google Body for tablets is
available in the market today.
So if you're looking for
something to do with your
tablets, you can
download this.
And it's basically
the same thing.
So there's a 3D view
of a model that
you can move around.
You can zoom in, zoom out.
Look at different
layers up here.
You have a search box
where you can--
I don't know-- search
for skull.
Oh, it's right there.
You can tap on things.
So these things here
are called teeth.
And there's a fun bug where
I don't do modular
interpolations.
So if you spin the model a bit
and then click on the reset
view button it spins
a bit too often.
So that basically Google
Body for Android.
The cow is not in there yet.
But it'll come eventually.
So that's what I did.
And currently this is tablets
only and currently I am
working on getting this
to work on phones.
And I'd like just to share my
experience writing this a
little bit.
So Google Body was released
December 2010.
I did the port after that.
So they send out a mail saying,
anyone interested in
porting this to Android?
And I was like, yeah, if
nobody else stands up.
Sure I'll do it.
And then they told
me, awesome.
And we want this for tablets and
you have two weeks and go.
So my point is, I don't have a
ton of Android experience.
So I'm not on the
Android team.
What I'm saying is my personal
opinion; not an official
recommendation.
It might be factually wrong.
Parts are, probably.
And what I'm mostly focusing
on is doing
3D graphics on Android.
I kind assume that
you are somewhat
familiar with Android.
So who here knows what
an activity is?
Everyone?
Awesome.
Who here has used OpenGL
before in any?
Also most people.
Awesome.
Who here has done OpenGL
on Android?
OK, so not as many.
That's perfect.
So I think this talk is perfect
for you if you have
some experience with Android,
some experience with OpenGL,
but not so much with
the combination.
And if you are completely new
to Android, I gave a version
of this talk at the Game
Developers Conference
earlier this year.
And if you just do a web search
for GDC 2011 Android
OpenGL, you'll find this page,
which has a slightly more
basic version of this talk
with uglier slides.
So Google Body for Android is a
native Java app and it uses
OpenGL ES 2.0 for
the 3D display.
So let's see what I'll
be talking about.
So I'll very quickly tell you
what OpenGL ES 2.0 is.
It's actually faster than
saying the whole
word, OpenGL ES 2.0.
And then I'll give you
a very, very rough
mental model of GPUs.
Tell you a few pitfalls
with textures.
A few best practices and
pitfalls with geometry, that
is Vertex Buffer Objects.
Then I'll tell you quickly how
to quickly get data into
Vertex Buffer--
into ByteBuffers, which
you need to
upload them to the GPU.
And then I'll say a few words
about performance tweaks.
So OpenGL ES 2.0.
So I guess everyone
here knows OpenGL.
It's looks like this, right?
Looks familiar to anyone?
Awesome.
So OpenGL is basically
the 3D API.
There are implementations
on Windows,
MacOS, Linux, many phones.
It's been around forever,
so it's very versatile.
As I said, it's been
around for a long
time, 20 years I think.
And it has accumulated some
crap during that time.
And they are currently cleaning
that up, but by the
time they wanted to do 3D on
phones, OpenGL was kind of
messy, so they decided to
release mostly a subset.
OpenGL for Embedded Systems.
That's what the ES stands for.
And OpenGL ES is basically
OpenGL with fewer functions.
So they got rid of glbegin
and many other things.
And there are two versions
of OpenGL ES: OpenGL ES 1
corresponds to OpenGL
1, more or less.
And it has a fixed function
type line.
So that means every model you
draw will do vertex transform
and rasterization and some
predefined lighting
functions and so on.
And there's OpenGL ES 2, which
roughly corresponds to OpenGL
2, which has fully programmable
vertex and
fragment shaders and all that.
And Android supports both OpenGL
ES1 and OpenGL ES 2.
If you do a web search for
Android OpenGL you'll find
some official Android that
tells you-- that proudly
proclaims--
Android supports OpenGL ES 1.
And that's factually not wrong,
I guess, but it also
supports OpenGL ES 2
and that's what you
want to use in practice.
And I think they are updating
their documentation there but
they are not there yet.
And just as an aside, WebGL
is basically binding
for OpenGL ES 2.0.
So in theory, mobile browsers
could support WebGL in the
future but they don't yet.
And WebGL is very exciting but
nothing that I'll talk about
in this talk.
Because Body for Android
doesn't use it.
So as I said, I'm currently
porting
Body 2 to mobile phones.
So I kind of need to decide
which Android versions I want
to support.
If you're just writing a tablet
app, you just support
Android 3.0 That's easy.
But for phones you need to take
a look at this chart,
which is at
developer.android.com/blog.
And Android 1.5 and 1.6
are less than--
I think are about 5% of the
market share these days.
So I don't think it's really
worth supporting.
Android 2.1 is, I think,
about 24%.
Which is pretty sizable.
Android 2.2 is at 65-ish%
and Android 2.3 is 4%.
And that adds up to
about 100, I hope.
So Android 2.1 is the first
version of Android that
supports OpenGL ES2.
But only in the native code.
So they are no Java bindings
or anything like that.
So if you want to do OpenGL ES
2.0 and support Android 2.1
you need to add your own driver
bindings, which is not
hard but annoying.
And I personally haven't used
Android 2.1 at all yet.
So I won't say a lot about
Android 2.1 or anything.
Android 2.2 is the first
version that adds Java
bindings for OpenGL ES2.
So I think that's a reasonable
lower bound, at least for the
first iteration of your
project to target.
It also added support for
compressed textures, or added
API support for compressed
textures.
And many other cool things.
And finally, Android 2.3.
From a Java OpenGL perspective,
added only bug fixes.
If you're writing native code
2.3 added a lot of cool stuff.
But for just graphics
applications like Google Body,
I think Java is fast enough.
You're just pushing
data through the
graphics card anyway.
And Java is kind of like, the
better paved way to write
Android applications.
So Google Body is
written in Java.
And my plan is to port it to
2.3 first and then if stuff
works there reasonably well then
get it working on 2.2 and
maybe eventually onto 1.
I think no new project should
use OpenGL ES1.
I think 90% of all phones
support OpenGL ES2.0.
All new phones support it.
And if you feel that you really
want to support the
last 10% that don't support the
OpenGL ES2 these phones
are also pretty slow.
Weak CPUs, weak RAM.
So you probably are writing a
second, lo-res version of the
app anyway.
So I think every new app
should go OpenGL ES2.
So let's take a little look at
how you actually do this.
So the class that does OpenGL
rendering in Android is
GLSurfaceView.
And actually it's pretty
easy to use.
In your activity and your
onCreate method, you just
create a GLSurfaceView.
And then you say,
setEGLContentClientVersion to
inform the view that you want
to use ES 2.0, which has the
programmable shaders
and all that.
And then you set a render
object, which is your own
class that implements
GLSurfaceView.render interface.
We'll get to that in a second.
And then you also forward on
parse and on resume to the
view so that when your
application goes in the
background it stops rendering
and that stuff.
So that's all you have to
do in your activity.
Then in your manifest you just
add uses-feature ES Version
2.0, require true.
And that way the market knows
that the application requires
OpenGL ES2 and it will only
show it to phones
that support that.
And finally you need to write
your own little renderer.
So if you're using OpenGL
ES2 you call static
functions on GLES20.
So I recommend doing an
import static for
everything in there.
And then you can just so normal
OpenGL calls like you
used to do that in
other languages.
So you don't have to do GLES20
dot GLClear or whatever.
You can just write GLClear.
And this interface has
three methods.
One is on surface created,
which is called when your
context is first created and
then a couple more times.
We'll get to that in a second.
And there's onDrawFrame, which
is called every time you
should render.
By default this is called 60
times per second [? GLE. ?]
But you can also tell the
system to only draw
your view on demand.
And there's onSurfaceChange,
which is not very interesting
in practice.
So I'd like to do a tiny demo of
how this looks in practice.
Coworkers inform me that it's
too risky to go switch back to
Eclipse for demo.
So I'll just do this
right on my slide.
So onSurfaceCreated will do
GLClear, color, and a line--
some redder shade of gray.
And I'll also call the view to
not draw at 60 frames per
second but only when needed.
And in here we'll just
clear the background.
If I click this run button,
hopefully the code will be
copied into some Java file in
the background and then
uploaded to the tablet.
So it still says compiling.
So it says uploading.
Let's switch to the other box.
Now I just opened the
IO OpenGL app.
I switched slightly too slowly
to see it starting.
And that hardware makes an
accelerated flashlight app.
So, mission accomplished.
No, at just one frame because
it's when dirty.
So that's the OpenGL Hello
world, I guess.
And that's about 20 lines.
Not too bad.
So one cool thing that
GLSurfaceView gives you is
that it creates an educated
renderer thread for you.
All the GL stuff will execute
on the renderer thread.
Which means that if your UI
thread is overloaded, you
still have smooth rendering.
And if your rendering is kind
of slow, your app is still
responsive to tap events
and all that.
So one thing that you need to
do every now and then is to
relay an event from the UI
thread to the OpenGL thread.
Because UI land and GL land are
kind of single threaded,
so every OpenGL call has to
be done on the GL thread.
Every UI call has to be
done on the UI thread.
So for example, on click, I
guess that should be on touch
or something like that.
When on touch is called on your
UI thread, you might want
to tell the renderer to draw--
I don't know-- a particle system
at the touch location
or something.
So you need to somehow relay the
event from the UI thread
to the renderer.
So the way you do this,
you just call
.queueEvent on the GL view.
And pass a Runnable.
And then this will be executed
on the GL thread.
So if you want to, for example,
access item in here,
then Java has this mutation
that int has to be final.
So you just put a
final in there.
And then you can just use item
in here on the other thread.
One little pitfall there is, if
you want use a class that's
passed in, for example on a
touch event, and you just do
final touch event event.
And then use event down here.
And then by the time the GL
thread executes the runnable,
the UI thread has already
reused the
touch event up here.
Changed it internally
and passed it on
to a different view.
Because the UI thread reuses
objects so it doesn't allocate
memory all that much.
So by the time your renderer
looks at the touch event
object, the data is all
wrong for you to use.
So you should make a copy of all
parameters and then have a
final local variable and use
that in the runnable.
The other direction from the
renderer thread to the UI
thread isn't needed
all that often.
Just for completeness you can
do activity dot run on UI
thread and pass in the runnable
and then this is
executed in the UI thread.
In Body I used this, for
example, when you would touch
muscles, I need to see what
muscle was tapped.
And so I basically render the
polygons in some made up
colors and then I read the
screen and see what color was
below the finger and then have
them mapping colors to objects
and then tell the UI thread,
this thing was touched.
Use GLSurfaceView.
My advice.
That makes happy Android for
that, which is, I guess, kind
of like a gold star.
It's very easy to use.
It gives you a dedicated
renderer thread for free and
it's very well tested.
So some people on the internet
recommend that you run your
own little surface
holder thing.
For example, Chris Pruett, who
talked here earlier today, has
an open source game called
Replica island and he has his
own GlSurfaceView fork.
And he has one screen full of
comments about something that
went wrong.
Like, a few graphics drivers
misbehaved under very specific
circumstances and it took him
two weeks to track that down.
So don't be Chris Pruett.
Use GLSurfaceView.
A little word of
warning though.
GLSurfaceView loses its OpenGL
context very often.
So every time you call onPause
it'll forget all OpenGL state,
like uploaded pictures
and so on.
It'll call onCreate on your
renderer object and then you
need to re-upload all your
pictures and so on and that
can be slow.
So make that fast. If you're
talking 3.0 or later you can
call types
setPreserveEGLContextOnPause.
But if your device supports only
one OpenGL context and
the user switches to another
app that uses OpenGL and he
switches back to your app then
your stuff is gone anyway.
So make loading your data is
the lesson here, I guess.
Alright so that's basically
the OpenGL Hello world.
Here's a very high level picture
about how GPUs work.
So up there there's the CPU,
which executes your Java code.
And then there's this OpenGL
API, where all the data that
needs to be rendered needs
to be pushed through.
And then the data ends up
in graphics memory here.
And then the GPU reads
vertically to there, runs
vertex shaders, rasterizes all
the varyings, sends them
through the fragment processor,
which runs all your
fragment shaders.
And that's written to
the frame buffer.
So as I said, this is
very simplistic.
There's no planning
stage in here.
On some GPUs, vertex processors
and fragment
processors are executed
on the same
silicon and thus is shared.
But basically my point is, you
want to send not a lot of data
over this bus because
that's very slow.
And also many GPUs cache vertex
data pre-transform,
post-transform, they
cache textures.
So to make these cache
efficiently, you also want to
keep your data very small.
and if it And that's basically
how GPUs work.
Now you know.
My point basically is, don't
send lots of data to the GPU
on every frame.
And if you do, then don't do
it in many small calls.
Just do big, bursty calls.
So here's a piece of
OpenGL 101 that I
think everyone knows.
If you do GLTexImage2D with a
texture data at the end to
basically set the current
texture and then you draw your
model, then this will
upload the current
texture every frame.
And that's expensive,
so don't do that.
Instead, in your own surface
creator method, you create an
identifier for the texture,
which is just an int.
You tell OpenGL make this,
make texture--
I don't know-- number
five current.
Then you upload the data once
into texture number five.
And then in your onDraw
method you just find
texture number five once.
And then you call
it raw model.
So everybody knows that.
I'm saying this because nearly
the same is true for vertex
buffer objects later and it's
not as well known there.
You should also use texture
compression.
So ETC, which is short for
Ericsson Texture Compression.
So what the heading says
is use Ericcson Texture
Compression for RGB texture
compression.
An extension to OpenGL ES2
that's supported on virtually
all devices out there.
Or on all devices
that I know of.
And if you use ETC even every
pixel need only four bits,
effectively.
So that's compared to
16 bits per pixel.
That's a 75% memory win.
And sadly, iPhone, this isn't
documented very well.
So I didn't know about this.
So I launched Google Body
without doing this.
Then I read about this, enabled
texture compression
and that saved, like, 10
megabytes of Ram, which is
quite a bit.
So there's this binary ETC 1
tool in the Android SDK tools
folder that I didn't
know about.
So when I used this the first
time I did a web search for
ETC 1 compression and I found
some binary on some Erikson
website that ran only on Windows
and concluded the
source code didn't build
on MacOS so I patched
that and used this.
Turns out there's a binary
in the Android SDK.
It's just nobody tells you.
Nobody told me, at least.
And if you then add
supports-gl-texture to your
manifest, then the market
knows about this.
And the Android is happy again.
Hooray.
And it's very easy
to load textures.
So on your I/O thread you just
do ETC1utilcreatetexture and
pass in input stream.
And then on your GL thread, this
loads the texture into
memory and then on your GL
thread you can upload this.
Obviously you never want to do
I/O on the UI thread or the GL
thread because I/O can be
unpredictable and might just
take 100 milliseconds and you
don't want your UI or your
rendering to stutter, so you
should always have a
dedicated UI thread.
One small word of warning.
If the width or the height is
not a multiple of four, then
the PowerVR GPUs just display
noise for your texture.
So for example, PowerVR
is used on
the Nexus S for example.
In practice that's not a huge
problem because most textures
are power of two sized anyway.
And most powers of two are
also multiples of four.
And for heads-up displays, you
can make your texture sizes a
multiple of four.
Something to keep in mind.
So now we know how to
upload textures.
Now the same for geometry.
So same thing as for
textures, if you do
glvertexAttribPointer and pass
the attrib data in the last
parameter here, then this
uploads all the
vertex data to the GPU.
And if you do this on every
frame, then you are copying
lots of data around.
So don't do that.
And this is, for some reason,
less well known.
The OpenGL ES2.0 example and
Android SDK does this.
So don't look at that example.
I guess the excuse is OpenGL
ES1 only supported this way
and they haven't updated this
since then, I guess.
So instead, just like with
textures, you create a numeric
ID then you bind this.
So Array_BUFFER is used for
attributator like positions,
normal [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
coordinates.
And then you do GL Buffer
data with your data.
And the same for the indices.
Then at run time you just bind
the array buffer and the
element array buffer.
And you pass zero for the last
parameter instead of data.
And that's way faster.
So it's quite faster.
So two things to keep
in mind here.
One is you need to have this
attrib data and this index
data somehow.
And these need to be direct
ByteBuffers, which I'll talk
about in a second.
And then, as I said, in call GL
Vertex attrib pointer with
a zero back here and
GL draw elements
with a zero back here.
And if you run this on FroYo,
your application will crash.
And the reason for that is that
they forgot to add the
bindings for these
two method calls.
So it compiles just fine.
But at run time, when Android
tries to call the c method
that backs this OpenGL draw,
it doesn't find anything.
Which is a bit annoying but
it's pretty easy to fix.
You basically need to add
your own bindings
for these two functions.
So if you're familiar with the
NDK, that's pretty easy and if
not then I guess it's
kind of magic.
You just copy paste
and you're done.
Who here has used the NDK?
Not many people.
OK, basically what you do is you
create a normal Java class
and then you put your
method there.
But instead of putting
implementation there you put
native in front.
And this tells Java that
this method exists.
It takes these parameters and
that it should look somewhere
else for the implementation.
It's not implemented in Java.
And the same for the other
function that's missing.
And then you do a system dot
load library down here in the
static initializer.
And then this is something
you write with the NDK.
So you create a jni subfolder in
your project and you paste
in this bit of code.
So there's a function with this
weird naming convention--
Java_com_example
_io_GLE20Fix_glDrawElements.
And Java uses this
function name to
associate it with a class.
So it starts with Java then
it has the package name,
com.example.io.
Then it has the class name and
then it has the method name.
In here you put the
implementation of your method.
So the first two parameters
of jnimethod are always
jnin and jclass c.
And then the rest are the
parameters from the functions.
So this is int, int, int,
int just like here,
int, int, int, int.
Only with a j in front.
So JNI is Java Native Interface,
which is basically
the technology you use
to call C from Java.
And then we just call
the C function
for our GL Draw elements.
And exactly the same for
vertex attrib pointer.
And then you copy this
android.mk file, put that also
in your JNI folder.
Go into that folder and then
you call NDK build from the
NDK and this will create
some library.
And then you do a clean build in
Eclipse, which will pick up
that library and copy it into
your APK and then you can call
GLE20Fix_glDrawElements and
then that works on FroYo.
So that's that.
Let me say a few words about
filling ByteBuffers.
So ByteBuffers are the things
that you pass through GL
Buffer data.
And it's basically a block
of raw C memory.
So if you're not
familiar with--
Who here knows C?
Are the same people who
used the NDK, roughly.
No surprise.
So Java obviously has
managed memory.
C doesn't.
And in some JVMs, these
memories live
in different areas.
And OpenGL needs to have the raw
C memory, for some reason.
You just need to know you
need to use direct
ByteBuffers for that.
And it turns out, doing
element-wise access on these
is pretty slow.
So you get a ByteBuffer
by doing
ByteBuffer.allocatedirect
and then some size.
And then if you want to load
data from a resource into a
direct ByteBuffer, don't just
get the input stream and
element-wise put stuff.
Basically don't read one byte
from the input stream and put
it into the direct ByteBuffer.
This is very slow
for some reason.
Behind the scenes this does
several method calls.
One JNI hop and so on.
It's much better to
do this in blocks.
So in Body I think I used four
kilobyte code blocks.
And this sped up loading
by, I think, 8 seconds.
So it's still a bit slow, but
it's done in in parallel so
that's fine.
And you can do even better than
that if you are willing
to make some compromises.
So as you might know, APK files
are just Zip files.
And if you give your resources
some magic extensions, your
resources won't be compressed
in the zip file.
They will just be an
uncompressed part of the zip
file somewhere.
So for example, PNGs and JPGs
are compressed already, so
they aren't recompressed
again.
And also the extension, JET,
is one of these magic
extensions.
I have no idea what file format
this actually is.
But if I want to have a resource
that's not compressed
I call it dot JET and put it in
my response folder and then
it's not compressed.
And the cool thing about
uncompressed resourced is that
they are basically just a
chunk of your APK file.
And you can get a file
handle through that.
You begin to get a sense that
openfd, which gives you a set
file descriptor from which you
can get a file input stream
instead of just an
input stream.
And from a file input stream you
can then get a channel and
channel you can mmap.
And mmap returns a
MappedByteBuffer and
MappedByteBuffers are
always direct.
So in this case no conversions
at all have to be done.
You can just use this and pass
this through GL buffer data.
And this is another 10x
or so faster than
the previous thing.
So if you're willing to not to
compress your resources you
can have really, rally fast
loading this way.
So a small word of warning.
ByteBuffer dot allocateDirect
allocates more memory than you
tell it to.
So if you just do a tiny test
program that does ByteBuffer
dot allocateDirect with 15
megabytes and then look at
Lock Add and Lock Add
will tell you I paid
to allocate 60 megabytes.
So it overallocates by
a factor of four.
Which is an Android bug that's
being fixed, I think.
But not yet.
So keep your buffers
small, I guess.
In Google Body if you look at
the market page, there are two
one-star comments that tell
you this app is crap.
It's crashes all the time.
And that was because
of this bug.
Basically when Body was loading
and people pressed on
the screen, a lot of time.
So as I said, to do touch
detection i basically rendered
the whole scene into
a back buffer.
And I created an off-screen
buffer for the whole screen,
which is about a
million pixels.
And then two bytes per pixel for
color, two bytes per pixel
for that buffer.
So that's about four
megabytes.
With over allocation by 4x
that's 15 megabytes.
And if loadings going
on in parallel,
that's too much memory.
So Body crashed with
out of memory.
And I fixed that by not
rendering the whole screen
into back buffer but only
the 20x20 pixels
around the touch event.
So just something
to keep in mind.
And one thing that I also
learned is that, if you don't
have many users and you get
two one-star ratings, that
really hurts.
I used to have a 4.5 average
and then then it went down.
Tough times.
Another pitfall: compressed
files can be,
at most, one megabyte.
And uncompressed
on Android 2.2.
And the reason that is, I guess,
is because the Android
guys have a static buffer that's
one megabyte that they
use to uncompress in.
And if the uncompressed size is
larger than that they say,
sorry you can't do that.
So the things you can do there
are, split your files into one
megabytes chunks.
Which kind of sucks, so
I wouldn't do that.
Or you can basically use
uncompressed resources.
And then if you really need
the compression you can
compress them yourself and
uncompress them yourself and
you can be smarter than the
Android guys and use.
I hope everybody knows how
to write a decompressor.
Or how to use zlib, which does
the decompression for you but
don't have a static
max size buffer.
So they fixed that in 2.3.
And that's that about
ByteBuffer.
So that's already our
last section.
We're doing fantastic on time.
So I'd like to say a few words
about performance here.
The first word is measure.
So if you're trying to do
performance improvements,
always measure if they actually
help and if they
don't then don't do them.
And I have a little
demo for that.
About a little pitfall, I guess,
when you're measuring
performance, that I found.
So this little program here,
basically just clears the
color in the depth buffer
seven times per frame.
Which is obviously not a very
useful thing to do.
But it's interesting for
measuring performance.
As you might know, tablets are
fill rate limited, and this
can give you an idea of how much
fill rate you can get and
the best case.
So it turns out seven clear
screens is the upper bound you
can do to still get 60 frames.
So if you draw every pixel seven
times per frame, you
probably won't get 60
frames per second.
And that's with the cheapest
filling possible, right?
Normally you'd also
do some geometry
transforms and whatnot.
So I was interested in finding
out what this number here is.
So I wrote this program.
And let's run this.
So what this will do, it will,
again, compile the thing and
upload it to the device.
The device will measure how
fast it's drawing and send
that back to the laptop
and it'll hopefully
show up here on screen.
And for demonstration purposes,
the app apparently
measures the frame time every
frame and sesnd it.
So normally you'd want to
measure for the last second
and display an average
for the last second.
But if you do this for
every frame, you'll
see a curious thing.
Every frame either takes exactly
1/60 of a second or
1/30 of a second.
So that oscillates between 60
frames per second and 30
frames per second.
Or if you think a millisecond
per frame is better, either 16
or 32 milliseconds per frame.
And I'm not sure why
that is, exactly.
But my theory is
that the, oh--
gold star!
Someone suggests
it's the Vsync.
So Vsync is what the old tube
monitors use, I guess.
So I guess there's some kind of
double buffering going on
and the compositor that draws
the Android interface
basically only wants to
render at 60 hertz.
And if your frame takes just a
millisecond longer than 60
milliseconds, then you have to
wait for the next time Android
allows you to paint.
And this makes it kind of
hard to do performance
measurement, right?
Because if you're one
millisecond too slow then you
pay another 60 millisecond
a seconds for your frame.
And that makes it hard to
evaluate if any rendering
changes actually value
performance.
And as it turns out there's some
hack that happens to undo
this effect somehow.
So I guess it somehow enables
triple buffering, but I don't
know what's going on
there exactly.
I stumbled upon this.
So this hack is done by this
function, which I'll show on
the next slide.
So if you do this call here.
And it's compiling again,
uploading again.
And now you see that this is
a pretty constant function.
Just a little bit about over 60
milliseconds, which caused
this jiggering.
So since I don't really know
what this function does up
there, I wouldn't recommend
using it in your shipping
application.
But it's pretty useful
for doing performance
measurements, right?
So I guess double buffering is
what's causing this, somehow.
But who knows?
If you call egl--
you need to call some
function that's not
exposed through Java.
So you need JNI again.
All this code is on some Google
code site and I'll post
the link at the end so you can
play with this at home.
So if you call eglSurfaceAttrib
Swap Behavior
preserved, then this somehow
magically disables something,
or enables something, that
allows you to do better
performance measurements.
If you do a web search for swap
behavior, then I think
there's one page on this.
And this page tells you never
use GL buffer preserve because
it makes things slow.
And I guess that's true.
But on some hardware it allows
you to do useful time
measurements.
So this is on the Tegra
2 on tablets.
I guess also on your Samsung
that you got
also used Tegra 2.
If you run this on a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
it doesn't support this
attribute and just crashed.
So it's very dangerous but
useful for measurement.
So measure your stuff.
Now that we know how to measure,
let's see how we can
improve performance.
So here are the basics.
You always want you vertex
buffer objects.
So don't upload your vertex
data every frame.
Instead upload them into a VBO
and then only upload the
integer into OpenGL.
Always use index geometry.
So as most of you will know,
when you render two triangles
that are right next to each
other, you basically first
send these three vertices
to the GPU and
then these three vertices.
And if you send the four
vertices, then you're
basically sending this and
this vertex twice.
And that's expensive.
So in practice you usually
have only send indexes.
You say, draw a triangle with
vertex one, two, three and
then one, three, four.
And that way you only need to
transfer the index twice,
which is almost always a win.
So do that.
OpenGL gives you the flexibility
to either, order
your vertices by basically
have one chunk of memory,
where all the vertex positions
are and then another chunk of
memory, where all the normals
are, another chunk where all
the texture coordinates are.
But don't do that.
You should always keep one
vertex in a small, contained
element of memory.
So you want to have vertex
position right next to normal
or texture coordinate.
And then, as I said, there
aren't many caches
on some of the GPUs.
So you want to keep your
attributes small.
So for normals you can usually
get away with just assigned
u8, so assigned byte
is usually enough
resolution for normal.
For texture coordinates,
you might get
away with half loads.
So half loads are not officially
supported by ES
2.0, but like ETC textures they
are supported virtually
everywhere.
So think about doing this.
Also, since your code will run
on different devices, with
different frame rates, you
should make animation
time-based not frame
rate-based.
So if you have some animation
and some device renders your
app at 30 frames and the next
at 60 frames, the animation
should take the same length and
not be twice as fast just
because the device renders
twice as fast.
So that's the basics,
basically.
And now once you've written
your app and it's kind of
slow, the first thing you do is
you set the glViewport to a
1x1 pixel thingee.
And then either frame rate
goes up or it doesn't.
If it does go up, then you are
either fragment processor
bound or texture fetch bound.
And you differentiate that by
making all your textures
really small.
And if stuff gets--
if that doesn't help then you
are fragment processor bound.
And if that helps, you're
texture bound.
So if you're fragment processor
bound, there are a
few things you can do.
You can work from the fragment
shader to the vertex shader.
In my experience, fragment
shaders on mobile devices have
to be, like, one or two lines.
So you can't do lots of
fancy effect there.
If you want to do very fancy
lighting you can basically
pre-compute all your lighting
formulas for the resizing the
texture and then do a texture
look up instead of doing your
own calculations.
You shouldn't draw backfacing.
Strings that face
the other way.
And you shouldn't use discard
in your fragment shaders.
But the main point is
do less work in you
fragment shaders here.
If you're texture fetch bound,
if you're not using texture
compression yet, you should.
One thing that also helps is
to use mipmaps because of
cache coherency.
And of course use smaller
textures.
One thing I forgot to mention
on the ETC slide, on the
texture compression slide is
that ETC doesn't support an
alpha channel.
So if you have textures that
use an alpha channel, then
there's a not a single
compressed texture format that
works on all devices.
So in that case, you probably
have to download the right
compressed textures on
first run, depending
on the device type.
Or if you don't have many
alpha textures, not use
compression.
But if you're running into this
problem and not all your
textures are compressed
then try that first.
So if you're not fragment
processor bound, you're
probably vertex processor
bound.
So if using a very small
viewport doesn't really help
you, you're probably vertex
processor bound.
In that case, use fewer
small attributes.
So try using assigned bytes for
your normals, and so on.
You can play with the
position framework.
Position keyword in OpenGL ES.
You can do, instead of doing
lighting for vertex, instead
of transforming the light vector
into model space at
every vertex, you can, instead
transform the light vector
once and then read the
transformed light vector.
You can use level of detail.
And you can call objects that
are outside of the viewport.
So that's all the--
I guess, pretty normal--
performance stuff that's also
true on normal devices.
Finally if you are CPU bound,
then use less CPU.
So one thing that's expensive,
can be expensive, is if you
allocate memory a lot
in your inner loops.
In that case, reuse memory.
Batch draw calls.
So don't have a for loop in
your drawMethod type that
basically tells the GPU, draw
this triangle, now this, now
this, now this.
And loop for all triangles.
Instead have one call that
fetches all triangles.
And if all else fails, you can
look at the NDK and try to
write native code for your
time-critical functions.
In my experience, that doesn't
help all that much.
And that's that, I think.
So thanks for listening.
Whoa.
Watch me type my password.
So code, slides and so on are
available at this website.
If you do a web search for
io 2011 OpenGL Android
it might show up.
So the project used to be
hidden earlier today.
I don't know if it's
visible now.
So we have these feedback links
that are completely
impossible to pronounce.
So, goo.gl/TUMU4 if you want
to tell me anything.
And that's that.
And I'll download Body for
Android and play with it a
little bit.
So do we have any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Do you know how to
do OpenGL to a widget?
NICO WEBER: I don't.
I haven't looked at the widget
stuff at all, yet.
AUDIENCE: Aside from using
compressed textures, how can I
speed up the process of
reloading my textures when my
surface is recreated?
NICO WEBER: How do you
do the reading?
Do you just use the ETC1
text [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to read the texture, or?
AUDIENCE: I'm not using
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I'm writing for older
versions of Android.
NICO WEBER: So one thing that
I think might work, which I
want to do for Body but
haven't done yet , is
basically you read all your
texture data applications data
once and then you keep them in
memory cache ready for upload.
AUDIENCE: A memory cache?
NICO WEBER: Yeah, basically.
You keep them around so just
upload them immediately.
And if your activity
is [? on low ?]
memory is called you
drop these cache.
And then basically you have them
in memory already and you
don't need to reload them.
That's something I would try.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to get
some detail on that.
NICO WEBER: OK.
Maybe later.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have any issues
with transparency?
Because I know that it looks
like Body makes pretty heavy
use of showing some kind
of opaque model of
a translucent shell.
And in GL that can be tricky
to get order right.
NICO WEBER: Yeah.
So that's a known deficiency
with OpenGL.
So Body, I think, just doesn't
care that much.
So it doesn't look perfect.
But it looks good
enough, I think.
So basically, one thing you can
use so that-- the usual
way to do this is to draw your
non-transparent stuff first,
and then basically sort your
transparent [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
on CPU and draw them
back to front.
So that's slow, because
you need sort stuff.
There's this depth peeling
technique by Cass Everitt,
that means you need to render
the C [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
for that.
So I don't think there's
a good general
answer to that question.
You need to see what
works for your app.
In Body, I just don't really
care at the moment.
AUDIENCE: So what did
you do for Body?
Did you just--
NICO WEBER: I just say GL bend
mode one source of--
AUDIENCE: But you drew the
opaque part and then just--
NICO WEBER: No, I just
draw everything.
So Body basically has
these layers.
There's organs, skeleton
and so on.
And I draw the inner layer first
and the outer layer in
transparent doing the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But per layer I just
say, transparency
on and do your thing.
And I think I draw the
opaque things first.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
NICO WEBER: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So have you considered
using something
like the [?
SP3s so you can get the
transparency right?
NICO WEBER: Yeah, I have
considered it.
But it doesn't seem like the
most critical thing I should
be working on right now.
So as I said--
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
As a 20% thing.
Your spare time, other
than sleeping.
NICO WEBER: Well it's my
Friday, basically.
So I thought about that,
but I haven't done yet.
AUDIENCE: But I guess the
question is, do you see
problems in trying to
take that approach
with Java on GL 2.0?
Are you going to get hung
up on computation?
Are you going to get hung up on
pushing the indices through?
NICO WEBER: Try it, I guess.
So writing a demo for that
should take, maybe, two hours?
And then you know.
That's what I would do.
But I don't know.
So I guess if stuff turns out
to be slow you can always go
to native code.
But it worked on really slow
machines 12 years ago, or even
longer than that, so I guess
it should work fine.
AUDIENCE: Have you considered
or looked at Renderscript
by'the way?
NICO WEBER: So when I wrote
this, 3.0, there was even less
documentation on Renderscript
than there is today.
I think I had heard of a
name, but nothing else.
So not really.
And also I think Renderscript
is 3.0-only and
Android-only and so on.
So I think, not yet.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
NICO WEBER: Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you're using
GLSurfaceView and on top of
which, you might want to use an
Android 2-D graphics widget
or ListView, let's say,
the performance drops
tremendously.
I can understand there's 2D
computation, there's the 3D
computation in the background
happening.
But have you guys thought
about it?
Like how do you deal with
this in the future?
How about out combining 2D
graphic APIs and 3D graphic?
NICO WEBER: So with you guys, do
you mean me the Google Body
developer or us the Android
framework guys?
AUDIENCE: Generally
Android framework.
NICO WEBER: So I have
no idea what the
Android guys are doing.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Any tips and tricks
you might have seen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NICO WEBER: OK, so I am told to
recommend the Office Hours.
So what Google Body does, if you
tap things it draws these
little text widgets.
And I'm using OpenGL text just
for that because I didn't want
to deal with mixing 3D and 2D.
But I think Google Maps puts
2D, which is on top of the
map, and the map is
a GLSurfaceView,
so it kind of works.
So I guess it depends on if
you're writing a game where
you really need that 60
frames per second.
And in that case, you don't want
to put anything on top of
your thing.
Or if you're writing an app, in
that case it might be fine.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
NICO WEBER: More questions?
AUDIENCE: I've got a question
about the cow.
NICO WEBER: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Specifically, why
are its teats on show,
compared to the female model?
NICO WEBER: So I don't know.
The web version did that.
I hadn't ported the cow yet
to the tablet version.
So I haven't looked
into that yet.
Thought I can see the cow on the
tablet being really useful
if you go to a steak house
you can be like,
can I have this piece?
So that's my motivation,
there.
But I haven't had time yet.
What's that?
Oh yeah, that's pretty
fancy, huh?
So locally on the notebook,
there's a little ghost server
running that basically--
so I have a web socket
connection to the local ghost
server and then it copies that
into a Java file, invokes and
to compile this thing, then
invokes ADB to copy it over
and then ADB lock add to [? grab
the output for the frame
stuff, sends it back
up the web socket.
Yeah, that's also on
the slide project.
And this took way longer
to do that than useful.
But oh, well.
Yeah, the question was, how did
the run button work in the
presentation.
More questions?
Come on guys, we have
five minutes left.
No questions?
All right, then.
Thanks for listening, again.
[APPLAUSE]
NICO WEBER: Oh, there's
one last question.
AUDIENCE: In the fill rate
example, you cleared both the
color buffer and the
depth buffer.
I mean if you, actually
I was confused.
Does the fill rate work-- were
you trying look for both depth
and color buffer?
NICO WEBER: Yeah so if you just
clear the color buffer
then you can go higher
than seven.
So that's faster, if that's
the question.
But you can just try
it yourself.
AUDIENCE: I mean like the depth
buffer is like, you
don't write to it so often,
is what I got.
It's much smaller than the
color buffer, so--
NICO WEBER: I think the Tegra 2
has, it usually uses 16-bit
colors for performance
for the color buffer.
And the Tegra also only has
16-bit C buffers so
it's those same size.
AUDIENCE: Both are 16-bit?
NICO WEBER: Both are
16-bit per pixel.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
NICO WEBER: And phones actually
have, I guess, 32-bit
def per pixel, so you can get
some z fighting artifacts on
Tegra if you're not careful.
All right then, I'll just
say thank you, again.
And usually someone
else pops up.
AUDIENCE: It's not about
the cow this time.
The question was on, did you try
the fill buffer test with
textures as well and see what
the throughput was on that?
NICO WEBER: I think I did and
I think it was identical.
AUDIENCE: It was lower
than 7 per?
NICO WEBER: I think
it was the same.
AUDIENCE: There was
no difference?
So the fill rate is identical
for texture and
also uniform color?
NICO WEBER: I think so, yes.
Pretty sure I tried that.
But don't believe me anything.
Just try everything yourself.
It's easy and quick to do.
All right, that's all folks.
Thanks.